alright we're entering the realm of
spoiler talks already did my spoiler
free review of Batman Arkham Knight have
I ever done a spoiler talk for a video
game I don't know that I have sure it's
happened somewhere else but it's not
that common but this one requires it and
that's a fair spoiler warning right
there if you have not played Batman
Arkham Knight this is full of spoilers I
have done my part by warning you one of
the things I loved about this game is
the return of Mark Hamill as the Joker I
didn't expect that I didn't know that I
like keeping my nose out of the trailers
out of the gossip I like being surprised
I like that experience so when he showed
up I was like holy [ __ ] he's coming back
for one last hurrah and they do it in
such a clever way Batman's ultimately
losing his mind cuz he has like Joker
blood in him in the Joker's condition I
guess is like a blood disease is like an
STD or some [ __ ] so these people who
have had Joker blood transfusions
they're going nuts and Bruce Wayne is
one of them but it's such a great
concept and here's why because he will
show up to randomly talk [ __ ] how the
Joker would for the situation but when
we've seen that before it's Joker
talking [ __ ] fer the situation and the
Joker's perspective you left commentary
on what Batman's doing but it's not in
Batman's mind this time the Joker is
talking [ __ ] for what Bruce Wayne and
Batman know so it's the kind of [ __ ]
talk Joker would do given the
information in Batman's head that's
awesome maybe some great moments great
surprises great commentary by one of my
favorite characters if not my favorite
character of all time so jumping right
into the Arkham Knight the whole thing
is like what's his identity who is he I
was convinced for a large section of
this game that it was Damian Wayne
everything added up the arkham knight
was talking about how batman was
responsible for the death of his family
and it concentrated a lot about Talia al
Ghul and how Batman failed Talia al Ghul
even Joker in his mind came up to talk
about how he shot Talia al Ghul then
Batman failed her feels like it makes
sense Damian Wayne is Talia al Ghul son
Talia al Ghul died Damian Wayne wants
revenge for the death of his mother he
obviously knows how Batman operates so
it had to have been a Robin like Damian
Wayne I haven't seen Damian Wayne in the
Arkham universe so he either does not
exist whatsoever or he does and he's out
there somewhere he has a whole army some
of which use ninjutsu with swords made
sense that he'd go there and be like
okay it's the last al Ghul heir
Rachele Ghul is dead Talia al Ghul is
dead I'm running this [ __ ] now we're
gonna get revenge just made a lot of
sense to me that it would be Damian
Wayne then they start showing death in
the family and the Jason Todd Robin
being tortured by Joker another thing
that's great for Batman
to have the Joker in its head because at
that point you can show things like this
story I just liked seeing it in action
however when they were doing it I was
like okay so that's the arkham knight
right when they showed that joker
recorded it and sent batman the tape i
was like okay
the rule batman what's the rule in
cinema if it doesn't show him die they
ain't dead so at that point it was so
painfully obvious that Jason Todd was
the arkham knight but it was not a
surprise to me i was like i know exactly
who you are dude it's just easy to
deconstruct that [ __ ] end of the game
Batman gets unmasked the Scarecrow is
filming him Jim Gordon pulls the mask
off it's Bruce Wayne everyone knows it
and then it went into Bruce Wayne's mind
and this is what sold me on the fact it
was so well done the whole Joker taking
over things this I was sold on it is
when this Joker Batmobile comes through
and you just start wasting everybody
you're controlling it and at a point I
was like oh my god is Batman really
wrecking this is he killing people
you're walking through with the Joker
you're just plugging goons and at a
point you shoot I believe it's to face
and he kneels down is Jim Gordon his
life he's dying you're like but from
there it goes from the Joker being
completely liberated oh like Batman
statues are coming out of nowhere and
you're the Joker and you're killing them
off then from there it goes to him being
locked away it just does it so well and
so seamlessly I totally believe that
Joker took over Batman fought him locked
him away in his subconscious Batman wins
and after that he's not afraid anymore
takes down the Scarecrow done that's
right no boss fight yeah I understand
people are kind of solidly about that
[ __ ] I do get it because the biggest
showdown boss fight in the entire game
they build up the Arkham Knight so much
for like I'm gonna square off with this
dude your biggest fight with him is
ultimately you're going through these
sewer tunnels and he's chasing you with
the [ __ ] cleaner from labyrinth you
just gotta outrun it through a few
tunnels and you're fine the hand-to-hand
[ __ ] wasn't really hand-to-hand [ __ ] you
had to sneak up on him from under the
gargoyle to do that a few times and you
win I think it would have been better in
that scene before he's unmasked you
fight him hand-to-hand style unlike any
other boss fight in the entire game
really and then at that point after you
get the last lick he then knocked you
down he's like you don't know who I am
but I am and then that's the reveal and
after that do the sneaky [ __ ] because
yeah Batman doesn't want to pummel Jason
Todd but it's okay because after the
arkham knight leaves Deathstroke comes
back to gotham cuz you know once you
take out the militia checkpoints you're
gonna square off against Deathstroke
mano a mano and we're gonna know once
and for all through the purity of
hand-to-hand combat who is the greatest
combatant in Batman no indeed
see comics who Batman versus Deathstroke
one will stand one will fall until you
fight him with the tank that's what you
do yeah he has his tank and a bunch of
Tanks around him and you put the
Batmobile in tank mode and you fight him
tank style this is a big shortcoming in
this game at this point because I was
like this is Deathstroke this guy is
renowned for his fighting skills and you
fight him with a tank like he's just
some goon you fight a zillion tanks in
this games and now you got to fight him
in a tank and I was like alright maybe
when you blow up the tank he's gonna pop
out you're gonna fight him nope you
don't it's just that's how you fight
Deathstroke a tank
yeah fans are gonna be a little pissed
about that understandably so and this is
more to the point the Batmobile is being
shoved down your throat the Batmobile is
remarkably fun when it's the Batmobile
is like sex it's remarkably fun when
it's not being forced on you moments
like this where it's being forced on you
and you're like yeah I don't like this
but even with the Batmobile shortcomings
Arkham Knight is still a great game and
a great conclusion to a great trilogy I
love the combat I love the way the
integrated Mark Hamill as the Joker in
this game so well I love Conroy as
Batman I love John Noble as the
Scarecrow I love Mike Ehrmantraut from
Breaking Bad as Jim Gordon so now that
you've been able to play the entire
thing spoiler filled Batman Arkham
Knight have you played it what did you
still think about it replaced about the
Deathstroke fight for it I understand I
do whatever you think comment below let
me know and yes San Diego Comic Con is
upon us once again I will be there and I
have a couple of Comic Con panels I'm on
Friday morning I'm on the masters of the
web Comic Con panel brought to us by
John Campea and Friday night I'm on the
screen junkies movie fights panel live
movie fights no [ __ ] team ups like
last time yeah let's try not to do that
this time so if you guys see me I'll be
the only idiot in the smoldering heat
wearing a suit come up say hi I love
meeting you guys I love my fans I can't
wait to see you and in the end if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more